I want to show you guys how the devil
works, how temptation works, because I'm
on a long drive home from visiting with
my friend who just got married.
Congratulations Justin Writtenhouse and
Elizabeth for your marriage. And it was
such an awesome time and a trip, but
it's a long drive. And so I just pulled
over to use the bathroom. And check this
out. If you don't know my past, I used
to be uh a pthead, an alcoholic
um rapper. And I open my door and I
can't turn this camera around, but
this down here, I can see that this is
green in here. That is green. That is
not
uh tobacco. You can smell it.
That is not tobacco.
And um even smelling that takes me back.
And you know what? This is not a
temptation for me anymore. I swore I
would never do this because God set me
free. It's not a temptation. Look at
this.
>> I would never
do this. This is like
drug abuse is what they call this when
you or you know alcohol abuse. If you
spill a drink or something,
I do not want anyone to have this. I
would there might have been a time in my
life where I would have like passed this
on to somebody. But this
is satanic.
That might seem extreme to some people
to think that marijuana is satanic. Oh,
it's it's God created it. Just because
God created something natural doesn't
mean that you're supposed to use it in
that particular way. God created water.
But guess what? You can't breathe water.
You can't say just because God made it,
I can use it this way in my life.
Um, water is a great substance for your
body, but not if you breathe it. Just
like God's plants may have medicinal
value in certain forms, the leaves, the
oil, things like that, God never
intended for us to set a plant on fire
and deeply inhale it into our lungs,
causing smoking or causing coughing and
choking and red eyes and munchies. This
is not what God planned for that plant.
That is a perversion of God's creation
and I've been set free from it when I
was a slave to this thing, an addict.
People say you can't be addicted to
weed. I was addicted to weed and I know
many other people who are.
When you don't have it, you spend the
whole day looking for it. You're
irritable. You're you're snappy. All
this stuff. I'm going to run out of time
on this video, but I wanted to say if
you are still messing around with this
stuff, get rid of this. It is satanic.
It is sorcery. It is pharmarmacia. This
stuff affects your mind. And they're
start science is even starting to prove
that it can cause um mental issues and
things. God can set you free. Amen.